now where do you live the great libby
higgins i live in st louis missouri now
[ __ ] yeah
and everybody says that's the next place
uh-huh
no no i'm kidding no one has ever said
that or like
maybe someone said that like early 1900s
yeah that's probably but you're all
headed to nashville nashville the center
of the world now you love it down there
yeah [ __ ] yeah yes and and you're
building a compound we bought 100 acres
i'm gonna build a house
um a podcast studio a softball field
um i've got a roller rink oh god a
roller rink this is the dream yeah
this is [ __ ] awesome to hear 106
acres yep i'm gonna pull up an old uh
just a single wide trailer yeah i'm
gonna do it up real nice that's gonna be
my movie set for trailer trash tammy i'm
gonna film there
um i won't ever have to leave unless i
you know want to go to applebee's it's a
great it's a great idea to be to be
that's so ambitious
uh
to do to want to build more than just a
home
you want to kind of build a community
yeah and i would love to do that the
problem is i am surrounded by the most
undeserving blood suckers
[Laughter]
i mean the lowest of the low the least
talented
most dishonest
vengeful petty vindictive untrustworthy
scumbags yeah present company excluded i
guess
um so for me to even in my own mind
think about investing my time my money
my energy into building a community that
would only be populated by the literally
the worst of the worst
just people fleas ticks you know you
just need to be on your own deserted
island i just kind of like i like
a sparsely furnished cold house on a
cul-de-sac with a lot of other newly
developed houses where no one's really
home and you don't know if it's a
government testing facility
or if it's an actual neighborhood i like
a fake neighborhood where you go is this
a movie set
i like something like that that feels
uh like that
fake neighborhood easy come easy go yeah
you know what when now you're living
with grandma is grandma's not on meth
no
okay um but she was crazy yes what do
you mean by that what is that how do you
even how do you even discern that in
oklahoma well so i had two grandmas and
so i would go back and forth um were
they were they lesbians or just
different sides of the family no and i
was just about to say they were not
lesbians okay because that did sound
like they were lesbians i had two
absolutely which would have been cool
honestly great sitcom would have been
being made right now yes they're
lesbians and they're from oklahoma their
kids are on math but they're fun
oh my god um yeah live with grandma you
know i don't know um she was hard to
live with
um
she's still alive we don't have much of
a of a relationship wow um the whole um
like what i do now
uh kind of weird words are weirded her
out and you mean succeed yeah well
because she was used to raising her kids
and grandkids
you know like but isn't this better what
you're doing now than had you gone down
the road of math i'm having hot checks
i'm having a good time but is there a
little bit of her that's like resentful
or yes okay yeah yeah and now my family
resents me here's how i deal with it i
attack them mercilessly on the show
every single week and a bonus episode on
the patreon
[Laughter]
is that maybe is that
that seems to be a good way to handle it
i like it i like that yeah yeah but but
here here's the thing i do believe like
i kid i do believe in healing
and have you ever tried to sit down and
go listen you may not see eye to eye
with me but i want to let you know i am
grateful for what you did and thank you
oh yeah i actually have done that i did
that a couple years ago and she uh she
yeah still wasn't having it she didn't
she said go [ __ ] yourself funny yeah
yeah yeah wow so it's all right i'm i'm
chilling dude i'm having a good time
yeah you don't have to dwell on [ __ ]
like that
libby higgins do you even have a family
anyone connected to you in any way i
feel like you look like a girl who just
burned out an orphanage and got on a
boxcar it's like you know one of those
trolleys and just left town but i could
be wrong i have a sister but everyone
else is pretty much dead god blessed now
what happened to them they're just old
and dead
the genetics you spoke of i know
me and you look like we're related and
everyone we know died in a tornado
yes
everyone we know is strewn across the
wreckage i'm waiting for you to show up
on my 23andme i know i i i should i hope
i do close relative too and what does
your sister do
she lives in a missouri and doesn't
she doesn't do any of this that no she's
right
she's very funny but she's very afraid
of the limelight yeah play a little bit
of love libby higgins the uh
mcrib
the very funny mcrib sketch you know
what can i say something like that don't
rip don't don't give us a uh what do you
call it ben don't give us a strike or
don't don't uh copyright claims
libby almost did not post that mcrib
video she's she sent it to me
and she said i don't know if i'm going
to post it and i said [ __ ] this is
going viral you better if you don't post
it i'm posting it the reason i didn't
want to post it is because i said the
location just because i was improving
right and i knew that it was going to
cause them problems and it didn't and it
did well what does it caught what kind
of problems people call there people
send [ __ ] there that's fun if you work
at mcdonald's to this day you work at
mcdonald's problems are solutions like
each all your fighting is boredom so
right not for the mcdonald's endorsement
oh they were so mad at her every time
she came through the drive-through they
were mad like don't come back here
anymore oh you would still go back oh
yeah it was my mcdonald's oh that's
ballsy yeah
that is ballsy this is the great libby
higgins here
god it's so good i have an announcement
to make to y'all
to the people of america
i was at this here mcdonald's on dorset
it's uh monday night
i was just disrespected in there almost
got in a fight with the gal in there
first of all my first issue is the
drive-through was filled all the way up
and i had to walk inside
so then i'm you know i'm already mad
because i got to get out my car and go
inside so i go inside i politely say hey
um can i have a mcrib meal
large size with the dr pepper
and the lady says
okay that'd be
6 58.
i said ain't you forgetting something
ma'am
and she said well what
i said you supposed to offer me the
extra mcrib for a dollar when you buy
the mcrib meal
you ain't gonna believe it she looked
me up and down
and she said well don't look like you
need the extra mcrib
excuse me [ __ ]
i throw punched that [ __ ] i knocked her
ass down
so if you come to the
dorset mcdonald's and you see a lady
named charlene in there
tell a carla sent ya
and then you throw puncher or punch her
in the cooter i don't give a damn
this is against my civil rights
[ __ ] you mcdonald's
i'll endorse it not all the other ones i
like all the other ones
brilliant [ __ ] that's amazing brilliant
did you have a video of chelsea where it
kind of popped for you was there
something that oh yeah i don't i don't
know if anything's on youtube um
oh yeah i did a video my first viral
video was like in i don't wanna 2014-15
um
where i was i walked up to a car and
asked for a cigarette there it is down
there on the list there it is cigarette
where oh
cigarette oh
and this is the first one right there
the second one and listen by the way
yeah oh it's like a review oh by the way
i almost didn't post this video because
i thought it was the dumbest [ __ ]
thing i didn't think it was funny i
didn't think but i hadn't posted in a
minute so i needed something to post and
it just went like [ __ ] insane what
did you
when you started [ __ ] around online
and just doing stuff what made you do it
boredom right i had you know people
underestimate that you know when
everybody talks about how they figured
something out
people talk a lot about
you know inspiration all of these things
that clearly to a degree of matter you
know what people really leave out
boredom
is huge it's a big motivating factor the
reason that
we started doing this podcast is i got
bored with a lot of other things i was
doing and i still kept doing those other
things but like i felt like i was
hitting a wall creatively i needed to do
another thing something else add to it
and boredom is big
yeah i just you know when i started vine
in 2013 nobody there were no influencers
there were nobody was doing you know so
i never thought anything would come of
it i never thought i'd be doing it full
time or comedy it was just fun to you
know you were having fun yep yep i had
three followers and a reba t-shirt and i
just went to town that's [ __ ] amazing
this is and now let's take a look at
your dude yeah does it sit up at the top
yeah yeah i think so okay that's a thug
um we don't smoke
[ __ ] off
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey y'all got a cigarette um we don't
smoke
[ __ ] off
[Laughter]
[Music]
my most recent one was the roach tv
video have you seen that no no no
throw the roach titty video on please
roach
i don't know if yeah everything's on
like there you go this right here yep
okay
do you think pbs you know pbs public
television that we grew up with where
they'd have to do like
you know they would do like uh
fundraisers and stuff and they would
give away like things you know they'd be
like the pbs uh
andrew lloyd webber broadway collection
you know if you are a excelsior member
at 35 you will get not only to do i
wonder if like they're gonna have to
just start [ __ ] with online people
and they'll be like you know if you are
one of our presidential donors we will
give you the chelsea lin vine companion
including the cigarette video i'm dead
take a look at this
here we go
hahaha
that big floppy titty
that went wild
now yeah i mean